der countdown läuft meine damen und
herren in
43 einhalb stunden schließen die
wahllokale
und alles ist möglich
selbst in der zuletzt doch gebeutelten
cdu herrscht plötzlich wieder so was wie
trotziger optimismus haben sie das
gesehen diesen auftritt von laschet und
merkel in stralsund stehen dabei
strömendem regen und versprühen
siegeswillen wirklich aus jeder pore ja
um so nebeneinander zu stehen muss man
normalerweise 30 jahre verheiratet sein
abwarten abwarten wer weiß wie viele
unis am ende doch wieder ihr kreuzchen
bei der cdu machen 40 prozent der
wahlberechtigten in deutschland sagen
sie wollen mit ihrer stimme andere
parteien oder kandidaten verhindern
verstehen sie man wählt das geringere
übel oder wie man damals bei geh aufs
ganze gesagt hätte hinter jeder tür ein
song
eine gameshow aus den 90er egal wo vier
kinder armin laschet jedenfalls kämpft
er kämpft wie hier zum beispiel in der
rtl bürgersprechstunde ich will trotzdem
gern als allerletztes von ihnen fielen
wissen hat helga schütt sie heute abend
überzeugt einfach nur kurzes handzeichen
nicht so richtig also eher nicht so
irgend jemand
anzeichen jemand vielleicht der
kameramann
auch nicht ja schade 8 kommt der armin
der arminen ist gar nicht auf euch
angewiesen der hat doch seine
parteifreunde und diesen treu wie gold
immer noch tun sich viele wähler und
selbst parteifreunde schwer mit ihm auch
hier in villingen begrüßen sie gemeinsam
mit
ministerpräsident erwin
armin laschet
ich bin euer erwin lotter man mein gott
wie viel demütigung nennt noch für den
mann in der cdu läuft jetzt tatsächlich
schon das blame game wer ist schuld
dabei wissen doch noch gar nicht wie
hoch sind verlieren ob sie verlieren
schäuble sagt merkel ist schuld weil sie
mit dem parteivorsitz damals nicht auch
gleich die kanzlerschaft abgegeben hat
andere sagen schäuble schuld weil er
laschet als kandidaten wollte
kompromissvorschlag von mir die ganze
partei ist schuld weil sie jahrelang
gedacht hat wir brauchen kein programm
wir regieren doch überlegen sie wie die
alte machtmaschine cdu diskutiert
öffentlich über platz zwei die zahl
kannte helmut kohl gar nicht was würde
der wohl heute sagen zu seiner partei
das ganze spricht jeder jeder
betrachtung hohen ich bin nicht bereit
das zu akzeptieren
einen moment noch wer waren die spender
damals egal
armin laschet hat jetzt mehrmals
klargestellt er könne auch als zweiter
sieger regierung anführen nur zweiter
und trotzdem kanzler ist doch ein
wasserdichter plan wer sollte ihn noch
aufhalten nur wenn die union nummer eins
ist besteht die chance dann am ende zu
regieren
und wieder dem armin einen traum
zerschossen ja nur dafür steht das oder
morgens auf wie nennt man das einen
zwischen den beiden das ist wohl im
grunde so eine art super mario beziehung
markus söder geht schon lange nicht mehr
ums land oder um die union lassen soll
jetzt komplett scheitern und dann soll
man ihm den söder zu hilfe rufen ja
derweil holt olaf scholz um die liebe
der grünen haben sie das gesehen in
trient nummer drei
war wie don juan der scholz da ganz
offen die werburg angeschmachtet hat
endlich ihm so gar nicht zugetraut
das spd online tutorials flirten lernen
mit pick up artist olaf nur von ihm land
du die sprüche mit denen du jede in
deiner regierung wartet klassiker wie
und dann will ich auch kein hehl machen
daraus dass ich am liebsten natürlich
eine regierung bilden würde zusammen mit
den grünen
olaf ist ihm die er der hamburger bagger
könig verrät dir seine besten lines du
bist so heiß du musst der wahre grund
sein für die erderwärmung oder auch hey
baby hast du dein lastenrad falsch
geparkt dann würde ich dich gerne
abschleppen über die 1000
gesichtsausdrücke von pick up artist
olaf verliebt
verführerisch und
natürlich erregt wie kabarettist olaf er
kriegt sie alle
ja wirklich mal abwarten würde ich sagen
frau berg das fällt mir auf ist
jedenfalls viel besser in diesen duellen
seit sie weiß dass sie nicht kanzlerin
werden muss und scholz ist ein absolutes
phänomen wenn er und seine partei haben
in 12 von 16 merkel jahren mitregiert
aber das sollen wir jetzt irgendwie
vergessen hier neuer spd spot ganz
wichtig mich von uns
[Musik]
das ist ein stuhl
darauf sitzen ist einfach aber kaum
jemand ist diesem stuhl gewachsen mit
deiner stimme kannst du entscheiden wer
auf diesem stuhl lassen
deutschlands zukunft
das ein
sehr gutes zeichen wenn deine eigene
partei die so farblos findet dass sie
stattdessen lieber einen stuhl zeigt bis
corona hat scholz zum beispiel die
schwarze null verteidigt und zwar immer
bei den öko parteien haben alle großen
reformen in den letzten jahren
konsequent liegen lassen wieso
mietnomaden die die post nicht mehr
aufmachen rente rechnet sich bei uns nur
noch bis 2025 klima corona schulden
riesen loch bei den krankenkassen europa
eingeklemmt zwischen china und usa ich
sag mal viel spaß nächste regierung
was immer das für eine wird mike i nia
helgoland keiner weiß es mein
persönlicher horror sag ich ihnen
ehrlich wäre ja die sogenannte
deutschland koalition also das möchte
man gar nicht zu ende denken noch mal
eine groko aber bloß fdp und jetzt kommt
der eigentliche albtraum an die steuer
bleibt verkehrsminister
nur leider nicht völlig ausgeschlossen
deutschland koalition oder kommt
vielleicht doch rot rot grün also eher
zweig beziehungsweise wie heißt das
wovor der lindner ständig warnt sie
wollen aus unserer hauptstadt ein
bullerbü machen berlin zu einem bullerbü
bei aller liebe zu astrid lindgren und
bobby klimaschutz bei bullerbü
bullerbü
müller bullerbü genau
erinnern sie sich noch da gab es doch in
den sechzigern diese wunderbare
schwedische kinderserie in der ja damals
schon schonungslos gezeigt wurde was
genau passiert wenn in ballaballa die
grünen und die roten regieren
wir kinder aus bullerbü haben die
schnauze voll von bullerbü
nach der wahl haben sie alle unsere
häuser in bullerbü rot gestrichen und
nächste woche werden sie enteignet wir
spielen den ganzen tag nur analoges vor
neid weil das internet in bullerbü der
letzte rotz ist das ist das einzige
windows das bei uns ruckelfrei läuft
früher hat uns papa mit dem porsche zur
schule gefahren jetzt haben wir nach
genau 1 ps du wirst verbrenner verbot
hier hat die kleine kerze erfahren dass
robert habeck finanzminister wird sie
heult seit einer woche
in der schule haben wir jetzt nur noch
denn der kunde und müssen unsere
lehrerin plötzlich norbert nennen warum
nur in der kolchose bullen müssen wir
kinder jeden tag bio gemüse aus der erde
popeln bitte holt uns hier raus bitte
bitte wir kinder aus bullerbü haben die
schnauze voll von bullerbü
verständlich ja mal abwarten wer am ende
welche mehrheiten hat im bundestag
sicher ist eigentlich nur eins es wird
noch enger in der alten hütte experten
erwarten den vollsten und damit
natürlich auch teuersten bundestag aller
zeiten wir schalten wir live zu matthias
matschke er besetzt im city bereich des
parlaments die ganz neu geschaffene
stelle des head of care management das
heißt ich stelle hier stühle auf
für den neuen freiluft sitzungssaal weil
drinnen kein platz mehr ist also als
provisorium für maximal drei vier jahre
haben mir sagt gehen aber schäuble
sollte mir matschke gehen sie zu oben
gebrochen stühle klar alles kreuer markt
würden wie viele denn sagt da keene
ahnung weiß man doch noch gar nicht so
leute ihr habt doch nicht mehr alle
latten am zaun
so genau weiß das tatsächlich im moment
noch keiner vor knapp vier jahren
kletterte die zahl der abgeordneten von
den gesetzlich festgelegten
598 bereits auf
709 dieses mal droht ein neuer rekord je
nachdem wie die wahl ausgeht ist zu
befürchten dass der bundestag bis zu
1000 mitglieder fassen kann
paul sind da efron ich bin heute ist
kriminell pause jedoch gar nicht von der
statik her wir sitzen da drin doch jetzt
schon die bei ryan air wenninger obskur
will muss über drei andere rubach
steigen und alles weil die beiden damen
und herren seit jahren keine
wahlrechtsreform auf der kette kriegen
und wer hat das ihrer meinung nach
verbockt ja schon klar herr welke ihre
satire fuzzis wollt immer den einen der
schuld ist aber so einfach ist das leben
halt nicht wir reden hier von einem
komplexen problem da kommen
verschiedenste faktoren zusammen
verstehe
sie sehen aber wenn ich das richtig
verstehe eine teilverantwortung bei der
cst 100 prozent verantwortung bei der
csu alle anderen parteien waren bereits
von einer echten reform mit weniger
wahlkreise wer hat verhindert der sänger
und seine murmeltier schänder weil sie
so viele direktmandate holen jedes
mandat der csu verursacht dann mir
ausgleich mandate und kostet pro
legislatur 40 bis 45 millionen euro
extra ist ja gut andere parteien holen
auch direktmandate leute wegen sofaecke
jetzt alle fünf minuten zum baumarkt und
hochstühle und bei der nächsten mal
holen wir dann den chinesischen
volkskongress die wird es nie mehr
reformen geben denn wie sagt der meister
yoda des bundestags wenn man den sumpf
austrocknen will darf man nicht die
frösche fragen so nämlich und weil wir
in der frösche gefragt haben kommen eben
noch mehr frösche angeklagt jetzt
wahrscheinlich leute von den hintersten
listenplätze ein reines filmmaterial das
nur die listen voll machen soll ja da
drüben sitzt schon die spd kandidatin
aus dem kreis vechta probe das fräulein
casey vom eichengrund die aber wollte
danach im bundestag aber jetzt musik und
wer ist schuld casey
ganz der brave bist so matthias matschke
matthias matschke so der wahlkampf fast
aller parteien wird gerade massiv und
organisiert gestört von querdenkern
wobei der afg nicht komisch die
radikalisierung der querdenker szene das
thema der woche auch hier gilt natürlich
bitte nicht alle in einen topf schmeißen
es gibt menschen die kritisieren corona
maßnahmen andere sind aus verschiedenen
gründen im skeptiker aber dann gibt es
eben auch einen radikalen flügel und der
wird immer gefährlicher das zeigt nicht
nur der furchtbaren mord von idar
oberstein das kann man bei jeder corona
dem museum stichwort übergriffe auf
polizei und medien selbst im supermarkt
drehen masken verweigerer durch
beschäftigte berichten heute in
zusammenhang mit dem mord über ihre
erfahrungen ja ich war auch schon eine
nazi pure eine dumme sei eine diktatur
ja und ich drücke es mal so höflich aus
wie irgend möglich wer supermarkt
mitarbeiter die für wenig geld und viel
infektionsrisiko jeden tag für uns
arbeiten angreift ist ein asoziales
stück
in rechten chat gruppen wurde der
tankstellen mörder regelrecht gefeiert
und harald lesch einen berliner fdp
abgeordneter twittert die
bundesregierung hat mit den völlig
überzogenen maßnahmen zwei jahre die
gesellschaft gespalten steht wirklich
und aggressionen geweckt jetzt drehen
die ersten durch die verantwortlichen
sitzen im kanzleramt und im kabinett
weißt du was halt doch einfach da eine
dämliche und empathisches und wer das
spalterisch findet leute wie alles sind
für immer verloren für den
demokratischen diskurs eine klar mit
einigen impfgegnern kann man durchaus
noch irgendwie reden manche sind ja
sogar regelrecht vom fach ist eine ganz
normale infektions kurve beschäftigen
sich damit wie ich bin mediziner
beschäftigen sich mit
ich bin seit jahrzehnten im
massagebereich tätig
ja was ich immer sage diese dämpfe von
massageöl sind nicht ungefährlich
wahrscheinlich macht straßenwahlkampf
für politiker zurzeit noch weniger spaß
als sonst alle paar minuten kommt so ein
masseur und gelabert dich voll mit
seinem profunden halbwissen wie hier
jetzt bei karl lauterbach der dann aber
kommen sie mal unerwartet hilfe bekommt
meine schwiegermutter glaubt
beispielsweise das wissen was ihre
schwieger holte mit ihrem gestorben der
einzige chance die wir haben ist nur
weil nicht alle zur impfung gehen
könnten längst ähnliche verhältnisse
hier haben die gleichen leute die volle
hütte stehen sich eine klippe nach der
anderen reinziehen erzähl mir was vom
risiko der impfung
ab sofort mein persönliches idol ich
verleihe er diesen mann den goldenen
endlich sagt es mal einer orden der
heute show am bande und
karl lauterbach ist übrigens nur noch
mit personenschutz unterwegs in diesem
wahlkampf wo sind wir bloß hin gekommen
der erwähnte harte kern der querdenker
bewegung will eben nicht nur die maske
weghaben der will dieses system weg
haben die träumen vom umsturz und zwar
inklusive rache fantasien für die zeit
danach das geht alles nach sofort was
ihr esst mehr jäger prozesse zwei
parcours geben und da werden alle
verurteilt werden die sowas angeordnet
haben naja nürnberger prozesse für
masken pflicht ich würde sagen der
vergleich hinkt schlimmer als joseph
goebbels ja wohl doch ganz gut dass die
szene inzwischen vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet wird wer als eingebildeter
widerstandskämpfer in einer
eingebildeten diktatur lebt hält gewalt
natürlich irgendwann für gerechtfertigt
für ein legitimes mittel und als ich
neulich noch mal gelesen habe wie viele
von denen auch noch glühende putin fans
sind da hatte ich direkt eine
geschäftsidee
sie sind querdenker und haben das gefühl
sie leben in einer diktatur
sie finden die deutsche polizei
unterdrückt die meinungsfreiheit
[Musik]
dann buchen sie jetzt unsere heute-show
busreise nach russland und lernen eine
richtige diktatur kennen endlich hautnah
erleben wie sich verfolgte opposition
wirklich
und dabei sein wenn bei wahlen putin
stimmen unauffällig in die urne gemogelt
werden genial nach immer noch nicht
restlos überzeugt dann buchen sie jetzt
unseren querdenker adventure tritt mit
dem bus zur gurren die wonach china nur
als one way ticket buchbar
ach da nicht für facebook hat gerade 150
accounts aus der querdenker szene
gelöscht wegen hassrede wenn man bedenkt
wie lange es ansonsten dauert selbst
vergewaltigungs drohung gegen
politikerinnen aus dem netz zu kriegen
wohl eher symbolpolitik von facebook
zufällig so kurz vor der wahl gerade in
wahlkampfzeiten drohen überall fake news
bitte nein nicht bei telegramm viel
schlimmer bei der tagesschau und solange
wir diese medien haben haben wir
letztendlich auch ein problem ich sage
mal mit wahlen weil viele menschen immer
noch diesen medien diesen tagesthemen
tagesschau und heute vertrauen und ist
immer noch nicht begriffen haben dass
das weniger berichterstattung als
propaganda ist ich dachte kurz leute
heute show sagen ja aber den heute
-nachrichten hat er natürlich recht
hans-georg maßen man kann es nicht oft
genug sagen kandidiert für die cdu und
wolfgang schäuble findet der mann denkt
die volle bandbreite der partei zitat
ende na dann herzliches beileid fake
news im wahlkampf hier unser service für
sie
ratschläge in die fresse mit friedemann
weise
theodor roosevelt hat mal gesagt das
erste opfer des krieges ist die wahrheit
und weil wahlkampf ja auch so eine art
krieg ist sind wir im moment umringt von
falschmeldungen zum beispiel dass da auf
dem foto ist garnicht roosevelt aber
egal das zitat ist auch nicht von ihm
sie merken immer aufpassen zum beispiel
hier behauptet er habe eine information
bekommen die aus insider kreisen der
bundesbank kommen soll das tatsächlich
beschlossen wurde dass ab oktober kein
bargeld mehr existieren wird in
deutschland interessanter fall aber
keine klassische falschmeldung die
bundesbank hat sich hier nur auf diesen
telegramm post vom wendler verlassen im
september sind fast alle geimpften tod
die haben sich gedacht wenn er im
september alle tot sind brauchen wir im
oktober auch kein bargeld mehr fall
gelöst aber sogar in seriösen medien ist
man mittlerweile vor falschbehauptungen
nicht mehr sicher die polizei geschickt
um menschen aus beiden häusern zu
vertreiben nein
doch knaller hat gelogen klar aber das
meinte ich gar nicht hier ist noch mehr
gefälscht das war nie im leben ein
echter journalist viel zu klein
eindeutig fake jede talkshow verliert
heute kostbare sendezeit bringen so was
hier ab morgen auch der faktencheck
morgen der faktencheck wir haben
faktencheck es gibt auch ein faktencheck
den einen oder anderen faktencheck
schauen sie mal nach was sagt das über
den zustand der politik beim aktuellen
sportstudio muss ich da auch nicht am
nächsten tag gucken welche ergebnisse
aus der sendung stimmten warum gibt es
so viele fake news auch das kann ich
erklären früher die vom 8 eine
viertelstunde tagesschau mehr
nachrichten gab es nicht und davon waren
allein vier minuten die lottozahlen
heute will jeder rund um die uhr neuer
nachrichten lesen deshalb kommen jetzt
auch die stories in die nachrichten die
keiner vorher überprüft vor allem wenn
sie von promis kommen die rapperin nicki
minaj hat letzte woche getwittert sie
lassen sich nicht impfen der hohen eines
freundes sei danach angeschwollen und er
ist jetzt impotent
das problem also außer den dicken eiern
die geschichte wurde zum politikum und
am ende musste sogar der
gesundheitsminister von trinidad tobago
wo der eiermann angeblich wohnt eine
pressekonferenz geben um der ganzen welt
zu versichern dass ihm kein fall von
monster kröten bekannt ist da sieht man
wozu ungeprüfte nachrichten führen
können ein genie der turbo gilt übrigens
jetzt auch zweig aber da ist das
geimpfte und geschwollene chef
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
mime hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
scheiß und sie töten - wollt dann
abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]